cool Thank You Pete for the introduction
and hi everybody so I think this talk is
kind of partly to to everybody that this
is kind of like an important topic in
data science and kind of part kind of
brief overview because I think it's a
topic that kind of people have maybe
shied away from a little bit
historically because it is actually it
may be perceived to be quite difficult
but I think the message that I'm going
to try to get across is that actually
doesn't have to be difficult and that
there's some advances particularly in
the last few years which have kind of
come a long way in helping has actually
understand how to do causal inference in
in data science and so this also I
understand maybe not so appropriate for
people who are not so much on the on the
data science side maybe more on the data
engineering side so when it comes to the
pleaing I'm hoping that it transfers
over and if any colleagues that you talk
to
you're more on the building models you
can like convince after listening to
this you can convince them that they
need to think causally so um I know that
there are lots of different ways of
breaking down data science and breaking
down machine learning and like thinking
of how to split models one common way is
maybe into three buckets and like all
good domains data science has lots of
different ways of saying the same thing
so if you don't necessarily recognize
predictive explanatory optimization you
probably know by some other terms as
well so predictive explanatory or
descriptive modeling optimization or
maybe prescriptive modeling but they're
all essentially kind of interested in
looking at like y equals FX just with a
different focus on maybe so for
predictions we're interested to know how
to generate wise for expansion models we
want to look inside and understand what
these relationships are so understanding
more about F and optimization kind of
trying to find a good X so kind of for
this talk and for the causal inference
in general kind of I'm going to be
talking more about the explanatory
models but I think kind of given that
you can always use an explanatory model
for predictions as well there may be
certain domains in which kind of
thinking about causal inference for both
predictive and a
are important and this is because
expansion models drive key decisions
this can be within businesses it can be
in very important domains like health
care and things so can whether this is
just used for decision supports not
necessarily just for making decisions
but it can you know it it can decide or
help doctors decide who gets medication
whose most need it can help kind of
companies improve themselves so kind of
if they want to look at their data
historically and then perform
interventions and changes to their
processes such that they improve you
they do this by looking at explanatory
modeling and so kind of like it's a but
it also only makes sense if kind of like
the models themselves are makes sense
and because we'd expect these
explanations that would get out of a out
of an explanatory model to to make
causal sense so something that a human
would understand now I was reviewing
these slides last night and realized
that I nicked them from a deck that I
presented in London and kind of I if you
come from the northern hemisphere this
this this slide kind of makes sense if
you come from the southern hemisphere or
a country like Singapore with very very
little seasons this is maybe kind of
like not quite so appropriate a slide
but obviously the idea that kind of you
know ice cream causing forest fires is
ridiculous and then likely and also kind
of you know ice cream being a diet food
is also ridiculous it's obviously driven
by temperature which I appreciate having
moved to Singapore only about two months
ago kind of things seems to be putting
seems to be staying pretty constant but
kind of like if someone wanted to use
the models that were building in data
science to make decisions based off and
they didn't see something inside that
made causal sense they would probably
question it right there be a lack of
trust and so kind of like my plea is
that you know we need to include causal
inference because otherwise you know
people won't use the models that we're
building they won't trust the models and
it'll become you know the famous phrase
is obviously correlation is not
causation and it's like some people in
academia go even further than that and
say kind of like you know well if you're
not actually considering causation at
all then you know you can't really do
anything
I would come on to some of the more onto
that a little bit later in fact actually
I've got a quote from one of the guy
guys at the bottom this slides Judea
pearl but so causal inference is a hot
topic in data science it comes in under
a few other sorts of names and you know
these are these are categories on their
own but they're definitely relationships
between them so aside from just wanting
to build causal models for use in in
society counterfactual fairness is a big
topic so kind of the idea that you know
maybe there is some bias in the data
that we're collecting and then can this
is going to have a knock-on effect so
the models that were building which
could be essentially it's known as
confounding it could be kind of like
leading to biases and so we want to make
sure that when we're actually building
models that they they are fair and
fairness is a very I don't know how many
people kind of go to some of the the
other big kind of NL AI conferences but
like fairness in the last few years is
kind of definitely been growing and
growing and growing and not stopping
there's also some close relationships to
reinforcement learning so this idea and
this is to a lesser extent but kind of
the idea that when we're training RL is
able to learn consequences and there's
able to learn what is going to make good
interventions obviously this doesn't
quite kind of maybe generalize in the
same way that we hope that a causal
model would generalize but there's the
idea that kind of this is not a like a
niche topic on the fringes of AI and ml
this is actually something that you know
actually relates into kind of other big
research areas as well so hot topic but
unfortunately quite a lot of machine
learning doesn't actually care about
causality I have this kind of a rather
contrived example where on the right
hand side we're just generating some
data according to system of equations or
kind of like you can think of it as this
graph and so we know we know what the
answer should be basically if we if we
look at the data generator on the right
and the effect is that we want to sorry
the goal is that we want to find the
effect of sun exposure on somebody's
illness and so kind of like if we were
to build a really really simple model so
like you know or
sprayers and we were to just add in one
one variable so just the the the
variable that were interested in finding
the effect of so the exposure to Sun on
illness we fit the model it gets really
poor performance right but kind of if
you look at the coefficient it's
actually very similar to to what we we
know is the true coefficient from the
data that we generated yet if we kind of
I add in more variables we get a better
model performance just the Machine
algorithm kind of is able to explain
more variants overall but it does this
in a way that then kind of makes the the
meaning the so the coefficient
completely wrong
for the for the variable that we're
interested in and this is obviously very
very contrived and it's a bit of a
paradox but it's it's just to kind of
like demonstrate and try it hits home
the fact that you know quite often we
don't know how the data was generated
because in the real world we're not
quite often able to control where we get
the data from it's kind of quite
observational now obviously kind of in a
perfect world we might be able to kind
of design how we get all of our data and
you know exist this does exist so things
like randomized control trials RCT data
mean gives us the ability to kind of
uncommon
almost by design what the data that we
then want to build models on top of but
obviously there's a lot of problems with
RCT data like you know kind of a it's I
mean when this when this does actually
happen it's normally quite small data
there may be in some cases like ethical
issues around actually putting some
people in a certain group and other
people another group so for instance
like in the medical domain and so it
doesn't really scale and so kind of you
know quite often we are kind of forced
to have to work with observational
observational data or observational
studies and but you know as I was saying
the problem is that this data was not
generated with the necessarily the the
the question that we have in mind so it
might be highly compounded the way the
data has been collected may be really
biased and kind of if we build models on
it blindly without actually thinking
about these things those
some like serious risk that we could do
something wrong as he's kind of like
proven by the fact that you know doing
the stupidly it can go it can go really
wrong right if we were to propose an
intervention based on the second better
model better in inverted commas to set
explains more variants it would be
wildly the coefficient of minus one
would be wildly off from the the true
coefficient of positive one so I think
there are two key challenges that we
need to solve when working with
observational data this is probably not
an exhaustive list I think that kind of
more academic people would then I would
kind of say that there's far more
problems but the two big ones for me are
finding the causal direction in this
observational data and second handling
confounding so and then this is the more
positive side of the of the of the talk
is about how this has been like shied
away from maybe by people in data
science community a little bit but
because it was maybe seen to be hard I
actually don't think that I think there
has been some definitely a lot of
progress in the last few years and I
think kind of you know there are
definitely some solutions albeit not
perfect solutions but things that we can
do and should be doing to make sure that
we are attempting to solve this as the
best we possibly can so on the first
thing around kind of identifying the
causal direction from observational data
there's a number of recent sort of what
I would term kind of like exploratory
data analysis algorithms I've come out
so there's things like the resis
algorithm the maximum likelihood
estimation causality algorithm
information geometric causal inference
algorithm and then there is this one
this one was actually published in
Europe's last year it's based on Colonel
deviances and I chose this one out of
the others because they they have a
rather strange term
they try and claim that larger
structural variability is a technical
term which I'll come on to explain in a
second but the idea is that like if you
if you take some observational data and
you derive the conditional distributions
from these observations and then as you
change the variable that you're
conditioning on in the causal direction
the distributions still
and seem to make sense but in the anti
causal direction they have they don't
make sense they have this larger
structural variability and the way that
the authors of this paper are proposing
that you then use this is that you can
kind of calculate some sort of like calm
graphs
complexity of the distributions and say
that okay if I've got lower complexity
this is more likely to be in the causal
direction and I'm putting like a big big
big disclaimer on this because like
these methods are not perfect by a long
stretch
nothing is perfect we obtaining
causality from this sort of data is
definitely 100% not fully possible a big
big disclaimer but it can help so kind
of like the way that we use this in my
role is that we use this as a first pass
we kind of say okay if this is a domain
that we don't necessarily understand or
this is a process that is like really
highly technical and we need we need
some help basically and understanding
what's going on we apply these
algorithms they give us a good first
pass they make us sound slightly less
stupid when we go talk to the client and
then we but the important thing is that
we do go talk to someone because at the
end of the day understanding causality
from this sort of data is only kind of
only possible if you really understand
the processes going on and like you we
do still need expert help so kind of
like finding a method to kind of give
you a first pass is great but then the
important step is going and getting some
expert help to understand properly what
the causal direction is and then this
then I guess you could argue that all of
your causal models are only kind of kind
of an expert's opinion of causality but
you know this even the fact that we're
thinking about this and the fact that
we're making the effort to to kind of
make sure that we go away and study it
it's kind of like a step in the right
direction I think like the reciting more
definitely more work has been done on
kind of how to assess confounding the
problem it's when it comes to how to
assess confounding is that people have
very varying views so there's kind of
like two different schools of thought
which don't really like talking to each
other in fact if you ever look at Judea
pearl
and Rubens stuff they like they really
like arguing with each other and they've
been doing this like since the 90s but
kind of again there is no perfect way
I'm not claiming that you know there is
one right way of doing these things but
the idea is that I mean taking the
right-hand side of the slide to start
with if we can get out of having to
handle compounding that's the easiest
way by far but if you find yourself into
a situation where you really do have to
to handle compounding then some people
use propensity score matching some
people use so Suzanne Athey has
published lots of papers on causal
forests so there's some kind of like
quite complicated still black boxy
models which they're claiming to be able
to handle compounding but then and the
topic that I want to talk about the most
because it's it's my academic background
and it's the thing that I kind of like
forced all my colleagues to use at QB is
Bayesian networks and I'll talk a little
bit about structural equations because
they to start with they they they kind
of relate to each other in the way that
what we're really looking to do is we're
looking to augment the models using
expert help so can i some people can be
a little bit allergic to this just they
can be like oh but you're baking in
assumptions well yeah sure but like all
data science is baking in assumptions if
you apply a linear model you're baking
in the assumption that all of your
features are independent almost
guarantee that there's not gonna be the
case kind of like you know we have to
make some assumptions somewhere and kind
of like if we can like stick to a
framework that allows us to be very very
transparent about the about the
assumptions that we are building in then
that's that's that's still fine right
your model is only kind of valid up
until your assumptions that you're
making so kind of like going to an
expert and finding a method that allows
you to help encode causality I think is
still valid so taking I don't know why I
designed all these slides so that you
have to look at the right-hand side
first and then the left-hand side I
think I need to work on my slide making
skills but so if you take the right-hand
side first because I want to talk about
Bayesian networks in more detail kind of
and look at the structural equations so
kind of like you know this is a very
simplistic way right it's probably very
quite old hat way
kind of like someone maybe sitting down
thinking about some sort of dynamical
system that they could design that
mimics the process a smarter way in my
opinion and I'm a little bit biased is
using kind of an approach known as
Bayesian networks now Bayesian networks
are if I haven't come across and the
before there's a there's an example at
the bottom they are directed acyclic
graphs and essentially they are kind of
ways where you can think of every node
is as a feature or your target and they
are kind of trying to capture the
interdependencies between the variables
that exist in your data so kind of like
the assumptions that get that get baked
in is that where there is an edge
between the nodes there is a conditional
dependence and everything that doesn't
is conditionally independent from from
one another but the reason why I like
these is that kind of when we learn them
there is a step in the middle where we
can learn a structure a domain expert
can come in and add in their input and
then we can go away and fit the
probabilities and that this is actually
quite unusual for lots of machine many
mods there aren't many models where you
get to step in in the middle and kind of
edit what's going on and help and help
them adil basically get more causal but
they kind of a little bit sidelined for
a long time primarily because they're
very computationally demanding so
actually the the learning of a structure
is has been seen as like a very very
difficult problem there's a few
different methods of doing it so you can
do based on constraint based methods and
do it based on stall based methods you
could even forget about the whole using
data to learn the structure and just ask
your domain expert to come up with a
structure for you and then fit the
probabilities but last year at Europe's
as well
academics came out with a new new paper
and I will talk very very briefly about
the maths if I'm allowed yeah okay on
the next slide about about that and
because I think it's super cool I won't
go into too much detail in it I never
looked at the boring nerd but kind of
it's it's meant that kind of this big
this big a blocker to using be ends like
the actual structural learning processes
kind of been
wrote it away a little bit and as I
mentioned kind of like this hybrid
approach where kind of like we maybe
like let the model learn a structure
from data to start with yeah a first
pass expert comes in adjust the edges
says you know I actually I think this
link that is the data found is spurious
maybe the data that was collected was
you know biased and we should remove it
or maybe I think there is a link here to
be made maybe there was a weak link but
kind of the algorithm didn't think it
was important maybe there wasn't enough
data but I can add it in and also we can
change the direction so if if the if the
structural learning algorithm picks up
the the wrong direction something causes
something the other way around then we
can fix that as well as long as we don't
introduce a cycle and then once we've
once we fit a Bayesian network
everything else kind of like just flows
like a regular machine learning model so
we can check our model performance kind
of if we're going to think about the
question we're trying to answer is like
how do we build explanatory models
obviously expansion models tend not to
be the most complicated things in the
world because we want them to be
interpretable so but the ends because
they are able to capture these inter
dependencies between the variables they
don't make these assumptions like say
like a linear model that everything's
independent they're able to normally
outperform other simple models and then
we're able to perform inference on them
so we can essentially query the network
and Judaea pills came up with a system
of being able to also implement
interventions as well so kind of
performing counterfactuals
using Bayesian networks I'll give you
I'll explain that in a couple of slides
but hopefully you'll allow me to deke
out for a little bit and just talk you
through if no one's seen this paper this
is one of like the best papers that I've
I've seen at neurons for like a while
and and I say this because it's so
simple like really really simple and
it's solved like a big big problem that
was a blocker to using Bayesian networks
so if you think of like structuring a
a way of describing these edges between
the nodes think of it as a matrix so
this is known as an adjacency matrix and
the big the big difficulty in learning
in the structure learning algorithms for
a BN was actually checking that there
was no cycles so which is like you know
quite a simple thing right
a cyclicity except that this was this
was stopping the stopping people from
using continuous optimization algorithms
and what the authors realized was that
actually the only thing that you need to
check is that you need to check the
adjacency matrix when multiplied by
itself again and again and again and
again again up to you know
well technically only up to as many
powers as you have nodes in the graph
but as long as the the the diagonal
continues to be 0 you're not ever gonna
introduce a cycle and kind of like you
know a matrix kind of and then the
matrix the power to matrix the power 3
matrix the power 4 etc etc this starts
to look a lot like just like in the
exponent of the matrix essentially they
were able to introduce this system where
kind of like just by checking the trace
of the exponent of the matrix they were
able to confirm that there are no cycles
in the graph which is so simple it's
like but it's not been thought of for
like 25 years so I think that's super
cool and then the author is also a super
super cool guy who is keen to work with
anyone ended in industry as well because
basically the problem for quite a lot of
academics is that it don't have data and
so kind of like if you if you ever reach
out to him he's a super cool to talk
about how to how he can use his methods
and how he can learn from industry as
well and so actually kind of just to
give a very very very illustrative
example because I appreciate been
talking a lot about theory things and
keralite not giving any concrete things
this is but I say no concrete things and
then say this is illustrative so kind of
I just wants to give an example of the
sort of network that we're able to build
for decision support in in pharma world
so kind of like this is something that I
built in in January it's wrong on
purpose because I'm afraid I'm not
allowed to share the actual thing
but kind of like isn't relatively
indicative of how kind of like we can
take all of these different diseases so
this was learned off some insurance data
and it's kind of like trying to work out
what the risk of a myocardial infarction
which basically just means a heart
attack is for having different diseases
and so like I just want to like pull out
a few key features of what the using a
Bayesian network would will give to you
so first it's these relationships
between the diseases it's not just the
relationship between the diseases and a
heart attack it actually kind of like
you can tell a story and you can kind of
you can see how so say smoking causing
obesity obesity causing diabetes etc etc
all of these are just to repeat some of
these lis links won't make sense on
purpose but kind of like you know it
means that it helps garner trust with
the people who are using these models in
the end which which they can see inside
it its interpretive all right you can
see these things you can see how they
connect to each other and you can see
how kind of like they causally could
drive each other then we get to get some
metrics out of these things so we get to
see that we can test the sensitivity of
either the the different variables
amongst themselves so this is denoted by
the the thickness of the edges basically
or you can see you can test the
sensitivity to the target that you're
interested in in this case an MI or
heart attack of myocardial infarction
and kind of like these are super
powerful more generally as well because
we if you think about putting this into
like a business setting say some of
these features are levers that you are
able to pull or like things that you're
able to intervene on in your business if
you're able to see what has very
sensitive edges these could be like
really quick easy wins that you could if
you make a change is going to have some
impact
whereas kind of things things where you
know there's a very weak edge and
actually if you change something there's
not gonna have a lot of effect you might
kind of go okay maybe this is a process
that's not worth changing so you can see
how this might generalize to
to the business world more generally but
kind of like in in in this specific
example with the the farmer case kind of
like because we can then query the
network underneath all underneath all of
these nodes there are essentially
probability distributions and kind of
like they are conditioned on their
parents so kind of like as we kind of
add evidence or as we add observations
to the data its Bayesian so update so
you update to get a new posterior and
then you can kind of like see okay maybe
we could use this to help a clinician
kind of work out the risk profile for
someone of having a certain disease we
can give it different criteria so we can
say okay at one point the patient is a
smoker we know that we know what their
BMI is we know how old they are they
have a certain disease they have an
increased above average risk of having a
myocardial infarction and we can see
that kind of a you know as we query this
in different ways that the likelihoods
change and the probabilities update
until and give us like very easily
interpretable results and kind of I to
go back to the generalizing generalizing
of this essentially this is this is how
we kind of think about all of our
explanatory projects at QB is that we we
want to take a historical data and we
want to kind of like train a model and
then we want to think about okay what
are the business interventions that we
want to make we want to shift the data
to kind of say okay what what if we did
make these changes and then we want to
see what the value of making these
chickens would be before we actually get
the business to do it but just otherwise
if we're wrong then that could be a very
expensive mistake and then we're able to
get the value of stake the this this
only works though if the model that we
trained is actually causal because if if
we're making an intervention and it
wasn't causal then we'd be getting it
potentially totally totally wrong so our
what-ifs could be very very inaccurate
so this is my point about it been very
important that we think about causality
early on or we get as close to it as we
possibly can so
just to recap because I was always told
tell people you're gonna say say it and
tell people again what you said so
apologies that I'm repeating but kind of
if we want to make decisions based on ml
then we should expect these ml models to
make causal sense unfortunately the data
that we actually have to work with is
more often than not always going to be
observational because like getting our
CT data is just that you're very very
difficult whilst people have like shied
away from it a little bit historically
there are now methods getting more
common that will help us to identify
these causal relationships and models
that might respect causality or
respected domain experts view of
causality exist and thanks to these like
recent advances in the structure
learning are now easier to actually
learn and deploy so thank you very much
I think I actually made it on time
excellent
[Applause]